s stands for symmetry is it
an odd or an even function have a look
at it
right again in case you can't remember
if you think of this thing as f of x
right f of x then you're going to input
negative x everywhere and then see what
patterns you observe so for instance
when i put this in when you cube it
it'll be this and you'll get that
okay now is this
is this either exactly the same
as this or is it this with a minus sign
out the front
and the answer is no it is neither of
them it's quite obviously
not the same it's quite obviously not
the same you only really get the same
thing when all of your powers are even
hence even symmetry in the same way it's
not an odd function either what would i
need to what result would i need to get
here
in order for this to be an odd function
what difference
idea minus one wouldn't i once you got
that there
okay now this actually is going to
produce for me
an even function is it not like because
all these negatives are going to cancel
okay so you get even symmetry if i
wanted it
to be an odd function i'd need
uh what would i need what would i need
which minus should i get rid of probably
the bottom one because then that's just
one of them okay
so now you can see that's the effect of
putting a minus sign out the front and
brackets
so there you go that would give me an
odd function i don't have either of
those
so unfortunately i don't get to take
advantage of this symmetry
but it was a pretty quick thing to
work out
that that okay so it's out of the way
next step factorize okay now admittedly
we haven't looked at this for a while
i'm gonna get rid of this since it's not
useful to us
um so we don't do much work with cubics
but
that numerator there it can be
factorized
how do you factorize it
it's going to be all right now if you
can't remember the sum and difference of
cubes
okay the sum of the difference of cubes
uh this is the way the sum and
difference of cubes
works okay the first thing that i do
is i remember what are the pieces that
go into it and then i do the signs
afterwards right
so i know that it starts with this and
it goes
through like this these are the pieces
okay one of the ways i remember this is
that this bit in the middle here it
can't be a 2
because if it were to i'd be able to
factorize further
right i'd be able to make it well this
would be a perfect square of some
description
okay but it can't be like the whole
point is that this is as factorized as
it can go
okay now the last step after you get all
the pieces down
is to remember the signs and we use soap
right okay so
i'm starting with a plus so my signs
will be
same opposite always positive nailed it
okay so therefore in this context where
all i've got is x cubed plus one
right think about what your a and b are
going to be you should get this
opposite always positive done
i've factorized it it's not particularly
beautiful
okay but it's enough that's all i need
so from here i'm going to look for i've
factorized it so what am i going to look
for what feature am i going to look for
next
asymptotes very good so let's draw
ourselves a set of axes and start to put
this thing on here
there are hard asymptotes and there are
easy asymptotes which one's easy to spot
the vertical one you go straight to the
denominator you let it equal to zero
x equals zero that's my vertical
asymptote yes what happens if you
um there's no asymptote you can get from
there
if there is no vertical asymptote yeah
we'll i'll look at that next
actually if that's okay so in some cases
the denominator could never equal zero
so that means
no vertical asymptote you're going to
have to look for the
descriptive features of this graph
elsewhere
right so we got x equals zero that's a
plus
now we get to the harder part and this
is why this is the part that i'm
interested in this particular question
okay we're either expecting an oblique
or a horizontal asymptote okay now
immediately
we can rule out a horizontal asymptote
there's no horizontal asymptote here
and the reason why is
we look for the degree okay the degree
of the top is
three and the degree of the bottom is
one so the degree of the top is bigger
right in order for a horizontal
asymptote to emerge what uh what would
we have
if we wanted that yeah they've either
got to be the same
right or the bottom should be bigger
right make sense
and we don't have that so we're
expecting an oblique asymptote
but then the problem here um is because
i don't think i've given you other
questions like this
uh yeah i don't think so is that the
degrees
they don't differ by just one if you had
like x squared
something something something divided by
x just thinking about it in
polynomial terms right if you divide
degree two by degree one
you expect that what you get is degree
one
right like it's like an x squared
divided by an x you'll get an x right
in the same way if i bumped it up and
went degree three divided by degree two
again you'd expect degree one right
because like x cubed over x squared will
still be x okay
but here i have a difference of two
degree three degree one right so
therefore when i divide i
ought to expect not degree one but the
difference
will be two right it's just it's just
ordinary division it's just index laws
right now you can bear this out by
seeing do you remember we looked and we
saw
to find the actual equation of the
oblique asymptote
right to find if it's like y equals x or
x minus three or whatever
we had two ways one was the cheap way
which sometimes works and it's fast and
there was a more sophisticated way do
you remember what they
what they were what were the two ways
method one right it's when you get
something like this
if i if i give you this okay
this is very easy to just break apart
into two fractions right
when when the denominator is a mess you
can't break apart denominators but
numerators
you can right this guy would just be x
minus one on x okay i've broken it apart
i know that this part will go towards
zero so there
that is my oblique asymptote okay
method number two is if you get
something a little bit messier
so if i have say this uh there we go
okay i can't very neatly or
straightforwardly break that apart so
what do i do in this case
i have to resort to polynomial division
long division
uh it's not it's not a fun process it's
long right long division
but it can be done and then you get an
answer at the end have a look
which result which method would you
resort to in this case
you can do method one you're just
dividing by x this is pretty easy right
so when you divide it one of them will
be x cubed on
x which is x
and then the other part will be one on x
okay so then you look and you're like
all right i've already isolated that
part
that is going to be approaching zero
okay so all i'll be left with therefore
is x x squared
x squared okay what does x squared look
like well
uh that's what x squared looks like
right
be weird but that's what the algebra
tells me that's what i should be
approaching
okay now i could go a little bit further
and go a little bit further
um let's just think about uh we've done
asymptotes now
i'm done okay my next feature that i'm
after are
intercepts right um you can see right
away there's no y intercept
right so why understand because i've
already identified this acid terp so i
don't have to worry about that
there is an x-intercept though how do i
find the x-intercept
i look at the numerator right and this
is the whole point of factorizing
okay right there right there i can see
therefore
my x-intercept is going to be negative
one
so i'll check that guy over here okay
um you can go ahead and you can try to
solve
this quadratic over here but it has
those solutions which means
there are no other intercepts okay
last little piece uh regions regions
okay how are we going to do the regions
on this
um we're going to do it in i'm going to
do it in a kind of quicker way
right so you can see right you can see
i've got uh what's happening over here x
plus one
is one of my factors okay so i'm going
to put that in green
there's x plus one x is another of my
factors
it looks like this and then we have one
last factor this awkward quadratic guide
now a question i received was
what happens when you can't factorize
that anymore like
x squared minus x plus one that's as far
as it goes okay
and the answer is think about it why are
we drawing these factor lines
the reason the factor lines are useful
is because we know when they're positive
we know when they're negative and so we
can combine them to work out the whole
thing
okay now i've accounted for this i've
accounted for this
we just determined by going through this
process of trying to find intercepts
we just determined this will give us no
intercepts this this thing never equals
zero
correct okay but at the same time it's a
parabola
right and it's it's a a parabola that's
facing upwards it's
concave up i can tell that because it's
an x squared not a
minus x squared that would be facing
downwards that would be sad
right so being that it never touches the
axis
and it's concave up right i'm not even
going to draw this factor in
because it's always positive does that
make sense
this guy whatever value of x you throw
in there will always be positive so it's
never going to change the sign of this
whole result
okay it's a little bit like if i said to
you okay
a positive and a negative okay we know
if you multiply or divide these
you're going to get a negative right now
if i just add another
positive number in the mix and i tell
you
it always has to be positive okay what
effect did i have on the sign
answer no it doesn't change it okay so
therefore
it doesn't affect my regions so i'm not
even going to draw
it if i were to draw it it would be a
parabola up here
and that's just clouding my diagram it
doesn't contribute anything so i'll just
leave it off
okay so therefore i'm now going to look
and i can see all right i've got two
negatives here
right two negatives here so therefore
i'm gonna be positive right all right so
roughly speaking so my graph doesn't
turn into a mess
i hope you can see and basically do you
know positive
negative positive can you see it can you
picture it
i'm not going to draw it on i'm not
going to color it okay i think i have
enough information
i think i have a knot let's just think
about to the left of this asymptote over
here
i have to go from positive to negative
and i have these two asymptotes that i
need to approach
okay so therefore it looks to me like
i'm gonna do
this kind of thing
what else can it do right like i have to
get
closer to this asymptote up here so
that's why i'm i'm hugging you
i have to cross this intercept and then
i have to start getting towards x equals
zero but never get there
right so that's all i can see now just a
little note like you know how we talked
about when you can cross oblique or
i wouldn't know like you wouldn't call
that an oblique asymptote because not a
straight line you call it parabolic
asymptote i guess okay
how do i know i don't cross that okay
the way i would think about it is come
back to this guy
this is how we got the parabolic
asymptote in the first place right
so when you do this i'm figuring out
this is negative
negative side so negative infinity okay
you're approaching x squared
when you're negative we're used to
thinking of this as
it's approaching zero it is approaching
zero but which way
which way is it coming from
now if x is negative very very very
negative
right then this whole thing is a very
very tiny
negative number does that make sense
like minus one over a thousand
or minus one over a million etc so
actually coming from the bottom
right it's x squared and you take away a
little bit when you take away
means you're underneath okay so this is
one of the ways that i can see
i must approach this asymptote from the
bottom or it kind of looks from this
this perspective from the outside okay
so that's how i know i don't cross over
it's just another way of determining it
and there's so i've done the left hand
side bless you
now i'm going to do the right hand side
again i know i'm positive here and i'm
locked in between these two asymptotes
so what would you guess that it does it
just kind of yeah
um it kind of looks like a parabola
it's actually nothing like one but i
mean in terms of the numbers but that's
what you've got
that's what you've got um i've got a
point for scale on this left hand side
because an intercept is there
i don't have a point for scale on the
right hand side so would you like to
give me a nice easy number yeah
one one how about one one cubed plus one
is two and then you divide by one
so it's going to be like one comment two
okay i don't know by the way if that's
right on the bottom
actually i don't know exactly where it
is but i have it approximately and
that's
for now all we need to know okay